[Musique]
moi je pense qu'effectivement il ya eu
du progrès de famille il ya quand même
des questions qui se posent toujours et
qui sont toujours d'actualité et on peut
le voir là la question est toujours de
savoir pour une mère à quel point elle
va pouvoir s'investir de façon extérieur
ou plutôt garder du temps pour pour être
près de ses enfants
ça fait appel aussi référence un peu au
partage des tâches à la maison
je pense qu'on a quand même évolué là
dessus mais qui a encore du chemin à
parcourir dans ce domaine là plus
largement dans le métier de sapeur
pompier ou dans l'engagement de
sapeur-pompier volontaire puisque 80%
des sapeurs-pompiers sont des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires
on voit quand même que bas il ya de plus
deux en plus de femmes qui commencent à
s'engager mais que parfois il peut y
avoir
soit une autocensure de leur part pour
se dire bah non je serais pas capable et
j'y arriverai pas soit parfois une forme
de pression aussi de l'entourage ou voir
même intra sapeurs pompiers pour dire
bah non pourquoi toi tu arriveras pas
c'est pas possible tu pourra pas tout
faire
personnellement à travers toute la caq
j'ai pu avoir moi je sens l'évolution
que je la vois l j'aimerais qu'elle
laisse aller plus vite en fait que ça
aille plus dans les moeurs de fait qui
est plus de femmes plus d'engagement
et parfois il peut y avoir des
résistances internes mais elle commet
elle commence à être quand même beaucoup
plus minimes filles i sar est plus
anecdotique que ce que ça pu être jusqu
alors
il saleh on a plus de réticences dans
des centres de secours où il y a très
très peu de femmes en fête à partir du
moment où on a atteint un certain
pourcentage de femmes dans les centres
de secours c'est ça ne se pose même plus
la question ne se pose plus et c'est
naturel et on ne regarde plus la
personne sous le prisme d'être une femme
ou un homme
mais sous le prisme être un sapeur
pompier voilà et c'est ce qu'on
revendique nou sé on est sapeur pompier
avant tout et on veut être considéré
comme tel et ne pas avoir de différence
parce que c'est une femme voilà donc et
ça ça se passe si on le voit très bien
dans des centres de secours où on a
atteint aller le seuil des 20% et où
l'intégration des femmes est complète je
pense personnellement que ça apporte
aussi par l'exemple que je peux donner à
mes enfants
en matière d'investissements au profit
de l'intérêt général
donc le message que j'ai envie de donner
aujourd'hui à ces femmes qui
éventuellement pourraient être amenés à
se poser la question c'est que oui c'est
tout à fait accessible l'engagement de
sapeurs pompiers volontaires et que oui
c'est tout à fait possible d'être maman
de d'éduquer ses enfants de façon très
convenable et en même temps d'avoir un
investissement au profit d'intérêts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]